this morning I called a special meeting
of the executor the chief executive in
Council decided to invoke the emergency
regulations ordinance to enact a
prohibition on face covering regulation
now this has been discussed for a long
time in a committee as the anti mask
legislation this regulation will come
into effect tomorrow the 5th of October
why do we need to have this piece of
regulation is because in the past four
months we've seen that almost all
protesters who carried evangelism and
violence covered their face the purpose
was to hide the identity and evade the
law and they have become more and more
daring so we believe the prohibition on
face covering regulation will be an
effective deterrent to radical behavior
it will also help to please in enforcing
the law in a moment the sector for
justice will be review on the content of
the regulation we know that many have
expressed support for an anti mask
legislation they have not started in
other countries there is a similar law
but I not also there are people against
the enactment of an anti Mass
legislation and certain they've
questioned a certain legal principles
and they have expressed concerns in a
moment I will invite the sector for
justice to give a response now what I
would like to say to the people of Hong
Kong says it is not an easy decision to
legislate to ban mass but given the
current situation Hong Kong this is
necessary decisions I would like to
stress four points firstly what we're
invoking is the emergency regulations
ordinance and under that we are enacting
the prohibition in face covering
regulation but that does not mean Hong
Kong is in a state of emergency the
chief executive in council has not
declared hong kong having entered a
state of emergency it's just that the
ordinance gives
the chief executive in council that when
we believe there is danger to public
order then we could act accordingly now
I don't think anyone will question that
in Hong Kong we have already seen the
scenario of a public order being
endangered so therefore we could invoke
the emergency regulations and then the
chief detective in Council could make
any regulations that are in line with
Public Interest so I'm a stress that yes
we are using the emergency regulations
ordinance and then the regulation we are
enacting is a prohibition on face
covering but it doesn't mean Hong Kong
is in a state of emergency but at the
same time the situation in Hong Kong is
does satisfy this requirement of
endangering Public Order and secondly
this regulation aims to end violence and
return us a peace I believe that is the
aspiration of all in Hong Kong and
certainly the regulation would target
those who use violence who understand
there may be other people who need to
wear a mask or cover the face because of
a legitimate need that's why in the
regulation there are assumption clauses
where there is a reasonable de families
and the needs of these people would be
taken care of so we believe therefore
the regulation has struck the right
balance in a moment the secretary for
justice or the secretary for security
will be giving a detailed explanation
finally I would like to say this is a
regulation so the nature is that it is a
subsidiary legislation piece of
subsidiary legislation
my- vetting that means when the alleged
council assumes or the 16th of October
the SL government will table this piece
of such legislation to the alleged
Council for consideration now finally I
hope the public will
and none saying what we're doing and I
appeal to the public that we should all
say no to violence we must work together
to let Hong Kong go back to the normal
Hong Kong a place where we can call home
my team will continue to go by the four
initiatives I announced earlier through
dialogue and through more studies
hopefully we could identify the
deep-rooted problems in Hong Kong that
we could respond accordingly in English
protests arising from the fugitive
offenders bill have continued for nearly
four months now over this period
protestors violence has been escalating
and has reached a very alarming level in
the past few days causing numerous
injuries and leading Hong Kong to a
chaotic and panic situation so he just
been listening there to Hong Kong chief
executive Carrie Lam announcing this
emergency legislation to ban the use of
face masks by protesters as was widely
expected she said that this would come
into effect tomorrow criticising the
protesters for what she called unlawful
and on unauthorized demonstrations this
is seen as an attempt from the point of
view of protesters to try to intimidate
them and as we've seen large numbers of
them out in the streets in Hong Kong
today with their face masks on Scot
Heidler is live in Hong Kong for us
there so Scot as expected there the
chief executive in acting this
announcing that she was enacting this
new emergency law that would take effect
from tomorrow bypassing the the
legislature under these supposed
emergency powers but as we've been
seeing on the streets there the
protesters remain undeterred about all
this
they do house them absolutely yeah no
she said to carry lamb the chief
executive of Hong Kong said that there
was a dangerous public order in Hong
Kong because of these protests and she
needed to do this to try to restore
order here it's very interesting you
know this is something that has a law an
emergency law dates back to colonial
days and it hasn't been enacted for over
50 years so she feels as though it's
important to try to stop the violence
she said in Hong Kong by enacting this
emergency law now what it is is it if
the police see anyone who's trying to
conceal their identity with the mask
they have the right to go over and tell
them to remove it or have it removed by
the police that is what they're doing
that's what's gonna move forward as you
said housing starting tomorrow obviously
that is not going to sit well with these
protesters whatsoever they will continue
to wear them they have said the people
here who have been out on the streets in
Hong Kong in anticipation of this
announcement they have been out here
they're wearing the masks you can see
and even before that even when there
were rumblings that this emergency law
might be enacted they have been saying
the same thing across the city now what
happened today there was a gathering
that started at lunchtime about two 300
people and garden pretty close to where
we are we're in the central financial
district right here at Hong Kong started
small and it grew to about 500 in this
garden and then they marched marched
about a kilometre to where we are now
there were thousands there knows a route
they took is kind of sneaking through
the the urban caverns here with
buildings and things and through
walkways and shopping malls and then
they gathered here shutting down this
major intersection and they've been here
now for almost three hours so this is
something they they're taking very
seriously these protesters what's
interesting interesting chasm you know
in in the lead up to Carrie lambs
announcement kind of heard from both
sides the protesters are saying this is
only going to make things worse like a
couple weeks ago Carrie Lam tried to to
tamp things down by holding a dialogue
with 150 people
that didn't do anything if anything had
inflamed the protesters more protesters
just saying that's what this mask laws
were to do she's making this attempt to
try to calm things down they say it's
going to have all right for the moment
Scott hired a life worse there in Hong
Kong we will continue to monitor events
there